günstig sei hallo wer bist du wie man
neue lokal nur noch die des über grund
wir müssen uns auch politisch
orientieren wir sie gar nicht schweiz
das habe das habe ich ja das habe ja
gesagt aber er ist im bundesheer leute
auf den server 8 ist schon aufgegangen
ja ich bin ich bin gut drauf gegangen
und die profis gut wäre frieden
von daher ich bin grad am arsch der welt
bei einer letzten fall durch den server
irgendwie ein bisschen ans haus kommen
lassen
6 seit dem 1
wir sind der über grund heftig über
grund alle egal wir müssen das andere
wie so ein spruch aus denken so keine
ahnung wie sich in der grund- oder so
lang lebe king junge däne
^ ^ dem über grundlohn um zum größten
teil über grund fand ich cool
ja das ist ja weiß es ja schon bei denen
wir brauchen ja irgendwas ist ja auch so
eine sonne so wir sind gewiss egal wir
sind ja über macht deswegen ja auch über
grund weißt du wir haben ja alles
erreicht was man in niveau erreichen
kann und ich bin doch wo ist unser phlow
über pros unser phlow irgendwie so krass
was machen wir in dieser folge luca
erzähl doch mal unsere tollen erlernen
du ich war in der letzten folge ein
bisschen herumgekommen in der welt und
habe mir so ein paar sachen zusammen
gesammelt bin mit nachrüstungen im
goldenen trikot einfach mal ganz weit
gelaufen ganz weit geflogen
dabei ist der server also halt
abgeschmiert weil ich irgendwie zu viele
trucks auf einmal geladen habe weil man
damit ja mega schnell ist und deswegen
bin ich kann auf dem weg zurück in unser
stadt habe ich mich im moment da sein
glaube ich es irgendwie irgendwas zu
suchen aber ich krieg dich so richtig
hin
ja ich möchte mal so wir wollen uns wir
wollen uns ja auch wüssten und wir haben
auch übrigens ein hauptquartier an dem
der ob jetzt natürlich auch fleißig mit
bauen darf
wir wollen das gleiche was ist im ich
bin zu hause wir waren einfach das
gleiche was im untergrund gibt nur halt
eine glaskuppel die nach oben geht und
so was hab ich auch schon mal ein
bisschen ein bisschen was gemacht das
ist das grund gebäude und wichtig seien
um bis zu den oberen lagen bäume bonzen
der stadt das ist einfach nur mal kurz
zu dir
ich bin gerade ich bin gerade in meinem
kiosk afe dass er eine direktverbindung
ich verändere auch schon sieben tage
nicht mehr auf dem server reicher lange
aufgenommen ab davor aber ja hier kommt
mein haus handys das was man denn
eigentlich erzählt mal deine beweggründe
warum bist du bist du der welt macht in
minecraft eu beigetreten
du meinst dem über grund ja natürlich
dass wir nicht von welt macht jede man
nicht immer den über grund du das war
ganz einfach so die die logische
entscheidung rechne also jetzt mal
ehrlich man muss einfach dabei sein das
ist gespannt ob es bei uns hier das ist
irgendwie so das was ich irgendwie
angefangen hab ist wie gesagt und ich
sollte schön aber ich würde sagen wir
können jetzt einfach hier so so richtig
so
so ein glas oha drei herzen macht war
bis nach oben und dann mal nicht
verbrenne ich hab halt
er ist er wieder in dasselbe wird und
professionelles erstes mit mitglieder
meeting und ganz voll
ich bin hier gerade professionell am bau
ja wie sich in rotherbaum heek an ihm
lieben bruder baum stehen dass das war
aber von funden von simon der wollte
direkt die zugehörigkeit unserer
wunderschönen organisationen jetzt
müssen wir mal ganz kurz die regeln kurz
festhalten im über runde
also wir beide sind mitglieder der
versuche natürlich wird man mehr
mitglieder zu kriegen ich glaube den den
kev der iss zu loyal zu patriarchen
wenig patriotisch doch das auch aber der
zu patria triert es ist auch nicht gut
genug aus welches als patriotische
patriot patriotisch hatte aufgepasst im
geschichtsunterricht
das ist kevin patriotisch dafür der der
wird auf jeden fall in dieser stadt hier
bleiben er wird sie nicht überwunden
anschließen wir sind ja auch noch einen
statt blau natürlich natürlich natürlich
das ganz klar wir sind nicht so direkt
dass wir sagen
jetzt nicht mehr wir sind jetzt so was
die stadt pink dass wir einfach nicht in
der stadt angehören
aber dieser orte baum den den mustafa
weg machen weil wir haben auf jeden fall
keine partnerschaft mit dem untergrund
das ist so wie bei uns wie spd und linke
sowie sports ich finde eigentlich mal
mein hauptquartier so als erste lösung
finde ich das gar nicht so ungelegen
partnerwahl wenn wir nicht sagt spd und
linke und den diktator
die methoden über kritische diskussion
der untergrund des gegen den der
untergrund ist gegen die diktatur
das heißt er eigentlich wir sind die npd
weil wir damit den sympathisieren oder
widerstands ab ich komme der
zwischenzeit mein haus wären keine
ahnung aber ich würde jetzt nicht den
titel oder uns auf die brust schreiben
wir sind die npd weil ich sehe uns schon
er auch so als als kämpfer der gerechten
auch irgendwo weißt du wir sind wir sind
dass wir sind die macht die sich auf die
waagschale legt wenn die justiz ja mal
wieder nicht sich im gleichgewicht
befindet wir sind wir sind wir die
ritter im goldenen glanz wir sind über
allem
grund die gala überall im grund dicker
ja also ich wie gesagt - hohe pyramide
bauen
für familien gibt es ja schon so hält
ist schon mitten in der landschaft sehr
langweilig so schlecht wie es denn hier
bauen
ich will einfach sagen wir bauen also
jetzt gerade bin ich aber dabei mal so
ein kleines anfangs hauptquartier zu
bauen ja das wird einfach mal was was da
stehen haben wo wir ein können und wo
wir uns lieben können
man muss ja auch irgendwie 6 unter
mitgliedern muss ja auch stattfinden das
hat nämlich die höchste priorität
und deswegen das habe ich jetzt
angefangen das war ja erst mal kurz zu
ende und danach können wir dann gucken
was wir noch so als als als große als
als eyecatcher haben wollen wie man das
ja professionell nennen kann und dann
bauen wir das einfach noch drum herum
und dann irgendwann ist halt das über
grund hauptquartier größer als statt
blau aber das okay das natürlich dann ja
okay ich weiß gar nicht wie ich mein
haus bei unseren kinos vielleicht
einheitlich zum startblock ich mache ich
mache ich selbstverständlich wartet
dieses skript als nicht glücklich
wasser wasser von einem stripclub ich
finde hier gar nicht wissen wie diese
hfc halben blöcke suche ich diese
microblogs nicht zu verwechseln mit
micro transactions diese microblogs
können wir eigentlich eigentlich kann
sie kann sich dem über gründen können
sich doch auch leute anschließend nicht
in stadt lautet sind oder hexer 30 auf
auf mit mitglieder fangen gehen
übrigens habe ich ausgeführt warum eine
spitzhacke die hat ja hier sind touch
deswegen baut die abo dass ich immer
brennen muss stimmen
neben blöcke a wie wikis jemand im 3
was ist bei dem passiert bei denen ist
jemand im treibsand soll willkommen so
oft sterben jedes alter nein aber wir
dürfen das sie haben nämlich das hat
nämlich heftig für den untergrund
gekämpft gestolpert über grund habe und
gesagt habe ich doch hast musst du musst
echt aufpassen
wir müssen wir müssen uns da wirklich
damit auch das bei den bisher ist in den
köpfen der menschen noch der untergrund
aber wir müssen das ändern weiß dass da
muss da muss nur noch über grund in den
köpfen herum schon morgens aufsteht da
müsst ihr direkt denken auch über grund
orgasmus ja sowas und dass das dass das
wohl einfach einfach direkt direkt das
erste was ihr denkt nicht er heute
klausur sondern lieber wenn er nach
hause kommt und was soll ich jetzt nicht
gerade einmal anstellen manchmal bin ich
so ich hoffe
aber das ist okay das ist dass ich finde
das nicht okay nach ich das mit meiner
ganzen ich kann irgendwie gar nicht
immer in meinem in meinem eigenen scheiß
suchen das kleinflugzeug mach ich das
mit einer hand so nicht tschuldigung
guckt internet-blogs die ehec so egal
ich kann nicht mehr suchen wie mamas
kraftakt total er warum geht das nicht
mehr existent schalter mit dem model
casting director marketing blog die hand
so in die craft aid to gaza hat
eigentlich schon mal irgendjemand
versucht verschiedene ist man kann auch
verschiedene pfeile machen bringt das
irgendwie was kobold error page the rock
oper euro ich habe keine ahnung und
hämmer aussieht
das funktioniert im schleim ball ja das
ist das ist gut das schön das freut mich
total
ich stelle mal hier eine sonne so eine
blöde befristung wollte ich mir aber
kräften
es gibt so richtige team nach kräften
ich hab ja kohleblöcke hey you in
irritiert komm ich zeig dir jetzt immer
etwas für kühle blöcke ich habe in dem
ich die jetzt einfach mal bei dir an dem
ding dann setze ich bin gar nicht da ich
werde jetzt übrigens eiskalt in die
hölle verschwinden und dort ein bisschen
xp fahren weil ich es möchte ich musste
mich meinem eine rüstung ein bisschen
ein bisschen upgraden damit wir im pvp
auch zumindest von der seite aus ein
bisschen deswegen das stadtarchiv
rüstung die frist um die möchte ich mir
eigentlich später mal machen weil ich
dabei die stadt bewegt bei mir meinten
alle kunden von sonys gerüstturm
verzaubern auch die hilfe ist ohne
nerviges gerissen und so viel besser und
kam deswegen besser die fahrzeuge
sondern als wir mit der tiefe so gut
umgehen kann die ist halt extrem schnell
das heißt da muss man pvp geübt sein
damit man damit an ständig an einer
restaurant-kette bei der nebst du musst
jetzt aber mal hier muss auch erstmal
zuhören ja muss abermals tieren die im
kino
ich war ich wirklich gefahr zu statt
gelb oder vielleicht sie wieder er
gehört ja klar wurden sonst schaffe ich
es packen
bleibt man allerlei dieser komische
wettereffekt bis zum statt gelb weg gen
osten gebracht
hallo was hörst du mich ja ich würde
heißt was macht
der brauch ich baue ihnen was womit ich
jadebusen kann in der mauthalle man was
soll das ich schaue mir so ein bisschen
gerichtshofs haus an der heftiges haus
oder deftiges essen vor allem die haben
so diese heftigen mob fallen alle weil
man mit ihm läuft dann aber direkt
richtige frank drops und sortiert sie
die automaten wie bist du hier einige
kisten sortieren durch auch noch alte
liebe sie reingekommen ja das eine frage
war einstein frei flut starb nicht
abgebaut
ich stecke die irgendwas abbaut kommen
dahin ist so über grund ist lieb und
nett und warum hat ein mieter hat bilder
von skeletten mit spinnen an seiner wand
da hat wohl jemand ein ganz besonderen
fetisch für ihr kommt alle rein ich hab
schon wieder so ein schnitt liegen schon
ja hallo ihr lieben leute ich bin ein
bisschen hier in innenstadt gelb habe
ich glaube ich noch mal zu statt gelb es
ist wunderschön
ich brauche also ich brauche jetzt hallo
hallo hallo
nach wesel sind die süß hier alle infos
rüstung und da so lange sagt beck jetzt
jetzt jetzt beschleichen sie mich so
jetzt ultron zu essen
die entscheidung scheint meine ganzen
rucksack ist noch voll mit der ganzen
klasse hier aber das eigentlich schön so
statt die machen immer angst wenn ich
mit denen reden kann machen die mir
angst
hänni bleib da ich komm doch gerade auch
so lass die mal angreifen ja ja genau
kein problem dass das das klarstellen wo
bis wo wir durch das portal gegangen wo
dieser pfeil ist bin dann ins haus rein
und jetzt höflich ist durch die gegend
einfach mit vorfreude und und viel spaß
jedoch muss aber aufpassen dass sie dich
gleich nicht dann irgendwie angreifen
oder sony stattet euch einen
wundervollen
ich meine ich wenn ich jetzt über und
stellt euch einen wundervollen besucher
ab dann denken die gleiche wieder machen
die so ein auf hier greife ich an
budgets wieso bist du hier
du weißt doch neben mir ich sehe dich
nicht angegriffen
also ich bin gerade im bikini naja ich
habe mich aber ich finde nicht den
sternen
stapi style der ist da oben auf dem dach
hedge die ich hier rum und der schicke
ich ich selig werde ich glaube ich
glaube ich muss mir hallo wir den herben
alu coni hat hier niemand gefallen
bakonyi autos mit getroffen sagt auch
wirklich eine wunderschöne beleidigung
ich wollte gar nicht treffen
das jetzt mal vielleicht aufhören ok ok
hediger ich würde die sache ist die ich
habe keines geldes wegen verbrechen
nicht kommentieren wie komme ich jetzt
auch wieder christian bau seien besser
ich wollte ja aber ich mache ich kann
alles so schnell schießen deswegen
bestimmt denkt debitor irgendwie in sein
haus eingebrochen aber da war der eine
blog ist frei der war von anfang an frei
so statt blau club und dann gehe ich
jetzt ein wenig in die hölle meine
lieben freunde hat halt nicht auf mich
wie ich warte schlicht und ergreifend
nicht auf dich jemand zu 3 vs jetzt auch
die tür offen und ist die bewerbung
eingereicht aus der keine offizielle
dort ist auch gar kein probearbeiten
hierbei über grund
ich habe schon wieder ganz das was wir
mit den schülern diese tollen blöcke
machen die total nach oben leuchten a
vun de france ist sich portfolio das ist
gut für das hauptquartier von hört
irgendwo drin
das ist ein bitte nicht nein
den sound alter was ist das was da noch
alles gelten okay das was denn ich habe
meinen job laut spiegel leuchtet kaputt
gemacht ja und jetzt komme ich zurück
komme ich zurück jedoch jedoch einfach
beim debitor ins haus rein
das kann ich nicht machen da kannst du
runter laufen dann ist ein portal das
für direkte statt blau wie komme ich
dann einige staaten stützen richtig ob
oft so stark es ist ja richtig spüren
die türen darf sie eröffnen dafür noch
keine blöcke kaputt machen das ist das
große die vitos kasselmann bist du bist
und formuliert schon wieder mann
sterben als rüstungs bert ist das wenn
du wenn du der aufnahme wird sich volle
kanne spox wo soll ich jetzt noch wird
euch jetzt nach und nach ihre dass ein
blog freien statt blau damit rein
ich hab' ich habe gar keine fixe wieder
dabei und soll ich vielleicht mal nicht
so weit springen immer brennen die sims
sind immer so als habe ich ihr wieder
statt blau gesetzt natürlich darf an die
kisten ein und dann habe ich die erfolge
nichts geschafft du die ganze sache dass
hier brauche ich nehme mal bisher
feuerleiter was andere wollen nicht
wollen ich freue mich wenn nicht so
viele häftlinge die bringen einfach nix
diese scheiße
das nenne ich mal mitkommen die
emmericher elektra am ende so dass meine
pvp skills hier das glaubst du nicht
über tiefere profi geworden bin mit den
jahren
ich bin nicht umsonst nennt man nicht in
den hippen hebt davon hebt die holstein
donnie walsh nein nein ich bin prinz
marcus von anhalt in alta badia in
arbeit werfen euch nicht mit mit luca
privat auf facebook befreundet ist der
leicht über den tag verteilt so eine
rotze das nicht normal ist eine
schulfreunde darauf und und was weiß ich
was im richtigen dreck meistens videos
von irgendwie dieses eine davon dieser
dame die darum rennen zu dubstep musik
bitte mit dem häuschen
ja das ist ein kumpel von mir dass ich
hatte waren als anderen grund warum ich
denn darauf markiert haben wir kennen
aber nicht
das video von cnet aber trotzdem dass
das es so alle zwei minuten landen von
luca irgendwelche fakten frauen oder für
mich trainingsvideos oder irgendwann
fern als freunde du hast mich
hinzugefügt gar nicht gar nicht quatsch
und auf facebook
du fällst du bist eigentlich gesehen was
ich mit meinen tollen steinchen immer
etwas gar nicht an über grund
des alters du hast gar nicht seine über
grundbasis nur das komplette was ich bis
etwas da bisher steht ist ja nur von mir
ich habe schon zwei sachen gemacht die
einfach einen lappen gemacht doch die
kabarett machen dazu drinbleiben gut
dass ich diesen blöden chocobo stadien
machen soll
es gibt zu wenig erfahrung für das ab
und es gab doch bis jetzt gehe ich mal
den im krieg ich das jetzt einfach so es
gehört ich mache das jetzt einfach so
was ist das jetzt im fleisch und im
playboy besteht oft aber ich glaube auch
wenn wir da folge man lieber luca darf
doch nein ja doch doch nein
doch thorsten intro idiot nie irgendwo
auf 19 minuten ich kennen truppe stimmt
dieses dieses www ging ganz normal
moment irgendwas mit du musst also quer
muster ich musste ja ja ja genau genau
genau ich hab' ich möchte jetzt mal ganz
kurz diesen stall ihr eben einmal stadt
roth hat ein portal zu eurer stadt und
höhe in einem roten berg versteckt
insiderinformationen okay dann ist man
was man nächste folge der put machen da
dürfen wir das nicht wir stehen auf
jeden fall schön wie wir können sie ihm
anders hin leuten guckt sagen böse böse
böse böse einer kurzen screenshot von
gemacht dauert meine lieben freunde
leicht gefallen hat dann kann sie gern
eine bewertung lassen und sonst nehmen
jetzt noch eine folge auf wahrscheinlich
sonst nicht in der lage bin